[Music]
hey guys it's price and the ladies of
London are here Sophie and Julie welcome
welcome to America thank you what's she
running away from my shoes taking over
mapperton
its biggest thing I have done in my
entire life over the husband's lines no
way season three yes it's very dramatic
season already how are you guys feeling
about it I mean it's definitely been a
real roller coaster thanks for everybody
I think we've all been pushed to our
limits really a huge amount going on in
our personal lives and you know some of
its been really challenging and really
tough and quite as painful to go through
a lot of drama and a lot of you know you
get this type of group together and
you're not gonna get anything you know
other than drama really because we're
all so different and we're all we're
also very opinionated I think and also I
think putting the camera in to the mix
yes just really heightens everything and
the producers won't let us talk to each
other yes camera would normally you know
patch things up quickly yeah sometimes
you have to wait a whole day till you
can film it yeah they are housewives
trying to pay business I just want you
to be on a mission to step on everyone
to be told what I can and cannot do just
like jokes we do we come to a good place
with Caroline this season or does it get
a rock caroline and i you'll see episode
4 that we we we work things out got it
so there you go we got through this
season together and we did come back
from it unfortunately we then had
another run-in like we're going to get
to a good place really right now no I
mean we're not a nicob place I feel like
everyone's allowed to have a break from
their friendships and I think we're
having a little break do I want to make
that better at some point in my life of
course I do
right but right now I think we both need
a bit of spare
[Music]
you